I think we have to change the
conversation in our society not in
Southeast Asia not in Malaysia not in
America
seven billion people need to change the
conversation of what success looks like
it is not to make a billion dollars it
is to actually wake up in the morning
and be in a good mood
you got your prospective baby happy to
be here
thank you for having me yes sir
I love you back I love you back
I love you back hello hello sit sit sit
sit
try to see I'm trying to see where the
mics are I'm going to I'm very excited
about today we're working backstage and
we're gonna do a bunch of Q&A first I'm
going to give a little bit of a cute
keynote but we're gonna be setting up
mics at some point so please get ready
for your questions so where do I want to
go so look there's there's a lot of
things that are on my mind and when I
think about why you would come to this
conference
what is always a big pressure and focus
of mine is how do I bring value for you
to coming to this event like you're not
here for kicks and giggles there's
something you're trying to get and when
I think about what somebody's trying to
get the reality is it's either the
strategy right the information of the
strategy or it's the tactics you know
there's two ways to go about this
strategy and tactics and so for me I
always skewed towards tactics because
it's practical like get happy or this
and that or mindset you know it's it's
super important but it feels like it
could lack the tangible notion to
actually get you there so that was my
framework for a decade over the last
couple of years a lot of the things that
I try to say and when I look at people
consuming my content and then why
they're not doing something about it
I started realizing over time that it
wasn't just the tactics it was important
for me to create the framework the
blueprint the strategy the why so it
allowed you to get there so many people
in this audience have a very good sense
of what to do but the reason they're not
doing it is because they fear the
judgment of others when they would
actually do it look it's very simple if
you follow anything arm or a lot of
other people are saying it's very clear
that this device has changed the
work of our society and whether you're
in Southeast Asia or America or Europe
or South America its Universal this has
changed everything from a practicality
standpoint but if you're fearful to go
in because it's not what your parents
want or because you're not willing to
pay the sacrifice of time and eat [ __ ]
for five years to get what you want it
doesn't matter that you're knowledgeable
that YouTube and podcasting and
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter or
LinkedIn work on this platform it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if I
sit here for the next 45 minutes and
tell you that in Malaysia and Indonesia
in Singapore in the collective Southeast
Asia
besides mainly in China that Instagram
story ads are so under priced that if
you spend a thousand dollars on them and
actually put good content in there
whatever you're trying to accomplish
will happen it doesn't matter if I tell
you that how many people here consume my
content raise your hands the reality is
and you probably know this there's not
many things that I believe in there's
only seven to ten things I believe in I
say them over and over every day in
different ways but if you consume my
content it's very unlikely I'm gonna say
something in this for thirty minutes
that's so different than what you've
heard for me it's kind of the way I
think about getting into shape you've
heard for twenty years that it's
exercising and eating right you just
wish it was a pill and that's how I
think about business it's not very
complicated you have to have a good
product and then you have to have
communicate that product and service and
then you have to do that over and over
and over again and then something good
will happen yet everybody wants to know
how to get from zero to a million
dollars or from zero to a million
followers fast fast as fundamentally the
scariest word for me in business
everything that has happened that's been
good to me is slow
when I how many people here are under 31
years old raise your hands
keep him keep him up when I was 31 years
old me keep him up don't be lazy when I
was 31 years old I was making less than
$100,000 a year working in a liquor
store building a business for my dad and
was going to be leaving three years
later owning nothing keep it up
under 31 I worked in a liquor store
bringing in people up at the register
you can put it down everybody wants to
get to a place very few were willing to
sacrifice to get there everybody wants
something and very few people are
executing to go there the amount of
people whose actions mat2 the ambition
coming out of their mouth is very low
there is no shortcuts there is no secret
there's no system or model there's the
very basic nature of this no matter what
you do in this room the customer that
you're trying to reach is either very
difficult to get to or very easy to get
to on your ability to understand what's
happening in the world what I mean by
that is there's only marketing and sales
there's marketing and branding and then
there's sales understanding how that are
different and why they're DIF important
and then understanding how to do
marketing and branding so that you're
not at the mercy of sales is an
incredibly important thing to do for
long-term success so for me I spend all
my time trying to figure out for my
businesses and for the businesses I'm an
investor in how do you build a brand so
that you're not at the mercy of sales or
other platforms how do I get you to want
to do business period regardless of any
other variable the only way to do that
is to bring more value to the consumer
the
you're asking for in yourself the main
reason that people struggle with social
media content being successful for them
is because when they post
they're selfish not selfless the number
one reason if you've been trying to grow
your audience on these platforms and it
is not successful
normally 90% of the time it's because
when you post your posting for yourself
not for your audience you want it for
you not for them period and for me that
has been the foundational reason where a
lot of my stuff has worked and so for me
my number one challenge Malaysia is can
you go two months with putting out
content that only brings people value
and creates nothing for you in return
you have to understand that intent
intent is the most important part of the
process if you're putting out a piece of
content just so it goes into your funnel
so that you can make money on that
person you're [ __ ]
let me say it one more time for the kids
in the back
if the second you post a video or a
picture or written words in your heart
the reason you're writing it the reason
you're recording it the reason you're
posting it is to get them into you so
you can sell them you're in trouble
because you may be good enough in the
short term to get some money upfront but
you will never build something long-term
in meaningful and until you understand
that you will continue to look for
shortcuts quick fixes systems and all
sorts of other horseshit to let you make
some money in the short term and that is
the macro vulnerability the and actually
I can leave now look I'll stay because I
think I'm contractually obligated but
the reality is is that I genuinely feel
that to be true so look here's what's
happening we've never lived in a time
where the attention of our consumer is
easier to get to the cost to do content
on Facebook Instagram LinkedIn you know
these platforms is super low it's super
low it's hard it takes time you need to
make a lot of it but the cost is low the
ads are low and even more importantly
the organic reach on some of these
platforms is very high I'll give you one
very tactical thing if you are not
producing content on LinkedIn every day
you're making a huge mistake let me
explain why LinkedIn today and remember
it's not up here but my last book
crushing it I see it right I didn't even
write about LinkedIn in that book I
wrote that 18 months ago and LinkedIn is
not even in that book it was that not
important I put every other platform but
18 months ago if I was here I wouldn't
even said the word LinkedIn today today
it is easily in my opinion one of the
most ridiculous places for you to put
content to drive your business because
the organic reach you could have no
followers on LinkedIn you could sign up
for a LinkedIn
count today write an article or make a
video about whatever the hell you do for
a living
post it and get more people to see it
then if you have 5,000 followers on
Instagram because the organic reach is
reaching new people the problem is back
to the first point I made on the other
side of the stage if what you're saying
or writing isn't bringing value to the
audience it's selfish for you to get
their money you're gonna lose whoever
holds their breath the longest wins
whoever holds their breath the longest
wins the quicker you go for the sale the
less leverage you have the more you try
to disguise your sale the more full of
[ __ ] you are this is the foundation and
the framework that is forever work for
me how many people here are
entrepreneurs raise your hand how many
people here work for somebody raise your
hand I just want to get a sense who did
not raise their hand in the last two
questions raise your hand my friends
what's amazing about this world and if
you're not following along in the first
15 minutes let me say it one more time I
believe that every business every person
has to produce pictures videos and audio
sounds for Facebook Twitter Instagram
obviously if you're in Japan you have to
do it for line obviously if you're in
mainland China you have to do for wheat
chat or Weibo you know if it was seven
years five years ago in Indonesia you
had to do it for path I don't care the
name you put it it's the social networks
where people interact that's where you
need to be the luxury of this market is
a couple things when I look at the costs
associated with the advertising on
Facebook and Instagram on YouTube it's
ridiculously low in this market even
lower than it is in the US and as you
know every day I yell about how
underpriced it is so imagine how good of
a deal I think you have to me the
concern
and I have my I've started this talk the
way I have is because I'm concerned
about what you're gonna say a lot of
people don't know what to say
they're they're insecure why would
somebody listen to me and so what they
start to do is fake it they start to
make pretend they're an expert they
start to wear clothes that makes it look
like they're successful they fake it it
will never work
it will never work what you're much
better off doing is documenting your
journey you don't need to be an expert
you need to be honest if you notice you
know sometimes I said it earlier if I
talk about the same stuff and once in a
while somebody will leave a comment or
even here it would be like Gary you talk
about the same [ __ ] I look at them like
do you want me to lie and make up [ __ ]
like of course they talk about the same
[ __ ] because I've been running
businesses for 20-plus years and it
works and when I look at other
businesses that work they're doing the
same thing I'm doing and then when I
look at other things
I see businesses sometimes that worked
for a year and then collapse cuz it's
what I've been talking to you about for
the first 15 minutes which is if you're
gonna be built on [ __ ] you're gonna sink
you like that one was good one I like it
too like a [ __ ] you know it's soft I get
it
judgment is very interesting to me I've
come to realize in the last three years
that it is judgment that is stopping 90%
of this audience especially when you go
into different subcultures it is scary
to me how many of you are not doing
things because you're worried about what
your parents would think you're worried
about disappointing your parents you're
worried about the leverage your parents
have and that is unbelievably true in
every culture but obviously quite true
in this culture judgement is the number
one thing that I need to break you out
of for you to even begin to make content
on social networks you don't need to be
perfect you don't need to be right you
need to stay in your lane you need to
talk about what you know you need to
talk about what your passion
about you got to talk about either what
you like or what you know but you can't
worry about the comments are you really
gonna live your life based on somebody
anonymous saying that you're ugly or not
smart yet almost everybody does the
amount of people that refuse to post or
stopped posting because of a negative
comment is remarkable or because of a
snarky comment by their brother or best
friend or girlfriend it's remarkable to
me how grateful I am how thankful I am
that I was parented in a way that builds
self-esteem confidence and it's and I'm
grateful and also sad by how many aren't
and the only way I know to how to break
it is to push positivity and optimism
and practical positivity into the
ecosystem if you're if you're if you're
sitting in this audience today and
you're not happy and I mean this like
really ask yourself are you happy it's
really been interesting to me to find
something that works which is you have
to change who you're listening to if
you're sitting in this audience today
and you're not happy you have to change
who you're listening to it's scary to me
that 85% of the people that are here
today are here for one reason they're
looking for something because most
likely a parent put them in a position
that hasn't allowed them to feel fully
comfortable and so what has gotten me
more motivated than ever around this
subject matter is this and I'm gonna
keep going back to it I would not be
giving this keynote 20 years ago because
living a life around putting out content
on a platform that could reach so many
people wasn't real when the internet
wasn't here it was harder to do what you
love it was harder to be practical you
couldn't work your day job and then
start a whole nother big career after
because it was late at night and the
internet didn't exist so there was no
scale
you know what we're gonna open a store
that was only open from 9:00 p.m. to
midnight
it wasn't practical it is now this is
like I wish everybody here understood
including me
how lucky we are to be living in a world
where the Internet is now a thing our
grandparents didn't have these options
we must take advantage of this and
everybody thinks there's a right way
there is no right way there's only your
way some people are great at writing
others are not some people are
comfortable in front of a camera others
are not some people are good at talking
others are not the fact that you have
the ability to control how you put out
information based on what you're good at
is remarkable I don't want you to have
the video blog if you're not comfortable
in front of a camera
it's the reason I don't write that all
my written content is raagh off on my
team taking the transcription of my
audio I can't write I've written five
New York Times bestselling books and I
can't write I'm serious this is
important I have a top 100 podcast and I
don't sit down and do a podcast I
stripped the audio out of my vlog can we
hear for d-roc he's sitting on the
ground
i deploy self awareness and self esteem
to reverse engineer myself to put myself
in a position to succeed it is my great
hope that I can inspire people to do the
same but it starts with being self-aware
and having self esteem I will give you
the tactics one more time I think you
should post on Facebook Instagram
snapchat like like it's the same [ __ ] it
works for everybody who does it the
problem is you're not doing it and if
you're doing it you're so selfish that
nobody wants to hear it you understand
in a world where everybody can put out
content it means you have to be good
bless you it means that you have to be
good the way to be good is to actually
provide value the way to provide value
is actually care what they think not
what you think it's like this keynote
this keynote is a hundred percent gonna
be content that brings you value nothing
else that feels different than if it was
something else and that's what an
audience understands and so I want to
put real pressure on the framework on
the concept on what's actually happening
here which is we are living through a
transitional transformative technology
known as the internet it is now finally
twenty-five years old and mature
everybody has it everybody has it all
the time and the whole world is getting
flipped upside down and you have an
opportunity to take a piece of it the
problem is everybody wants to take the
whole piece everybody's like Gary I'm
gonna build the next Twitter or uber or
face everybody's gonna build a billion
dollar company news alert you're not
building a billion dollar company how
about just building a company that you
like and makes you happy how about just
doing something you like every day
everybody's got it right like how about
bad
[Applause]
how about people in here realizing that
they have a job that might pay them a
little bit more than something else but
they hate it but they're not willing to
live in a more humble home or drive a
more humble car and so they have a
miserable job just to pay for [ __ ] that
they have to impress other people that
they don't even like how about that
[ __ ] conversation it has never been
easier um and I don't like using the
word easy but I'm gonna say it it has
never been easier to make a hundred
thousand dollars a year because of this
the problem is everybody thinks you have
to make a billion and the problem is
nobody has humility to live a hundred
thousand dollar lifestyle I think we
have to change the conversation in our
society not in Southeast Asia not in
Malaysia not in America
seven billion people need to change the
conversation of what success looks like
it is not to make a billion dollars it
is to actually wake up in the morning
and be in a good mood and whether that
is me who loves the game of
entrepreneurship so much that he goes so
hard every day because he just loves
what he does or if it's somebody who
only wants to work twenty five hours a
week because they all their other
passions are so interesting to them and
that's what is good for them we have to
allow for everything we have to allow
for everything because everything is
true and everything is real and you need
to figure out my biggest fear of my
popularity is that you think you have to
do it like me the only hope I have when
you look at me is that you try to figure
out your version of you that makes you
as happy as my version of me makes me I
want to remind everybody here I'm 43
years old which means when I loved
entrepreneurship in America nobody else
did it was not popular
nice cool so I loved this thing before
it was this thing and guess what when
the economy's collapse everybody's gonna
go off of entrepreneurship and go back
to a job and I'm gonna still love this
thing when it's not as cool as it is
today when there isn't sneakers and fans
I'm gonna still like it because it's
mine I've always done it and I always
will you need to figure out that for you
not what your parents think not what I
think not what the comments think you
yeah how are we doing QA can I want I'd
like oh there are the mics I see it now
okay real quick cuz I'm gonna do a
couple of minutes but I'm gonna do other
5-10 minutes but if you've got questions
there's mics all the way over there and
all the way over there so you just start
lining up now if you have questions
because I'm not gonna be able to get to
them all anyway so this is Wow you're
[ __ ] running I love don't push her be
careful jesus [ __ ] christ while we're
setting up for questions let me talk
about a couple other things and
hopefully that will lead to the
questions I'm going very philosophical
view on you right I think how many
people you have followed me for more
than five years
just curious probably not a lot okay
appreciate it some of you will know it's
interesting that I'm going hep higher up
it's uncomfortable for me I don't want
to be a motivational speaker I don't
want to talk in theory but I'd be lying
if I didn't tell you the reason I keep
going higher is because it's been so
clear what to do like I guess maybe you
can walk up but I write the books like
it's it's there I put it out every day
it's there what has transpired over the
last three years I'm like why are people
still not doing it I can like I can tell
you exactly what to do figure out how
you talk best pictures videos written
word audio post it on Facebook Linkedin
it's that basic that's what's led me to
all the [ __ ] that I start thinking about
which is why judgment insecurities lack
of confidence faking it which then
doesn't feel good after
so you're stuck because you know you're
lying right and so my biggest concern is
that when people push you to wealth
quickly inevitably you have to fake it
and the reality is that's why I talk
about documenting it not creating it
right
just film talk talk about trying to
figure it out that's real talk about the
judgment of others that's real but then
talk about your expertise what you want
to sell you know what what you have to
me a couple years ago six maybe five six
years ago I wrote a book called Jab Jab
Jab right hook the reason I did that was
to give everybody a framework give give
give and then ask when you give you need
to give when you ask you need to ask I'm
here to give this is a keynote I will
not sell you here this is a keynote I'm
gonna give but I'm also very comfortable
when my new sneaker comes out to post it
on Instagram and say buy it the problem
is most people when they give they give
with expectation that they're gonna get
something in return that is the non
definition of giving when I give I give
and if it doesn't mean that I when I
wrote Jab Jab Jab right hook I said give
give given and ask the way everybody
heard it give give give and then take we
have to slow down if you actually
thought about your life in a 50 year
window or a 80 year window you would
slow down everybody wants to succeed so
fast cuz they want to prove something to
somebody else that makes you vulnerable
that makes you vulnerable when you're
producing for more likes when you're
producing for more subscribers when
you're producing for more money when
you're producing for more fame it makes
you vulnerable produce to bring value to
the other party so much so that it
guilts them into doing business with you
I mean it you want to really build
something meaningful think about
producing
content in a way that is so valuable
that it yields people to do business
with you that is how I see brands that
win-win thank you in that in that vein
because so many of you produce consume
my content and I could be repeating my
tried-and-true things over and over and
that will bring you less value I'm gonna
move to Q&A because it will get me into
a place of saying new things and bring
you the most value so thank you so much
Malaysia thank you let's do it
what's your name
Brent and I'm originally from Orlando
Florida but now here in Gua support how
are you been good my question actually
isn't for me it's for my son he's 10 his
name's Giovanni Giovanni he wants to be
a twitch streamer sounds what he
struggles with his confidence so I'm
wondering if you can give him a few
words of what can you can do what type
of action you can take every day to
build his confidence Shivani I think the
question you know I see we're recording
this look when you're 10 years old
confidence is a very funny thing you're
still forming as a human but the reality
is is if you're twitching and you're
over responding to how many subscribers
you have or what your friends in school
are saying you're not going to be able
to be successful and so you're lucky
Giovanni to be able to start this
process now not when you're 45 years old
the quicker you get comfortable with
judgment of others the more likely
you'll be successful long term the way
to get your confidence up is to start
enjoying the push back is to start
enjoying people say that you can't is to
start enjoying the judgment of others
who don't understand if you're not
comfortable in your own framework you'll
never succeed thanks Gary you got
hello it's alright
hi Gary how are you I'm great um so I'm
a bit nervous no worries okay so my
question is a bit long so I hope you
guys don't mind
yeah so I'm 27 years old I'm from
Arizona my name is below and I came to
Malaysia when I was 19 years old and
there was trials that I went through
with me my sister and my family so I at
the end of the day I lost my mom so I
had to start working so I started this
business and cut story short the
business is still running until now I'm
27 I started when I was a freshman in
college the business did earn a lot of
money which we are studying it's a
clothing brand but the problem that I'm
facing is first of all I don't give a
[ __ ] what people think I never did I
never will
I used to sell in the street you know in
every single yep Street you can imagine
I've been there yep I've been in a lot
of newspaper newspaper from Dubai they
wrote about me you know I've been on a
lot of local TV channels here everywhere
but then the business I cannot structure
it properly I tried hiring firing hiring
firing and no one just wants to do the
[ __ ] jobs Gary like I don't know like
people are just is it me that you're
giving isn't I'm not giving the job
properly it's a hundred percent you even
the way that you're casting judgment on
your employees already makes me know
that you're not a good leader maybe not
maybe we're sir for sure I'm trying to
be one but I believe you I'm trying I
believe I've been hustling let me tell
you one thing about me and I know yes
sue me I only give advice that I know
the person can handle that wasn't fun
for me to say but I believe you and I
respect that and I believe you which I
respect but the answer is it's you thank
you and so the number one mistake that
people like you and I that come from the
street and work hard is we expect our
employees to work hard but the problem
is they don't own the business you can't
ask an employee to work as hard as you
or you create a fake expectation versus
how much you compensate
that's like asking somebody to love your
child as much as you love them it's not
natural you work for them they don't
work for you dear ox my boss I try to
reverse engineer him and so the biggest
mistake people make and why they can't
build scalable businesses is they have
selfish expectations of their employees
thank you appreciate it man makes sense
yeah but I'm just you know I'm mentally
tired from running this business you
know it just sell it no I'm not giving
up I'm not giving up when you start you
listen you need be careful and I don't
know every detail but it selling a
business doesn't mean giving up you
might sell it to put yourself in a
position to be way better you know I
learned every day I get that but you
know like listen perspective matters
when I'm listening very carefully to you
the first part was very easy I said you
just by the way you said it if you
believe selling a business means giving
up you're gonna be in a very big trap
you know like like if you're if you're
burnt out from it or kind of getting
close to it even if you're not fully
there you need to be thoughtful selling
a business or giving a 20% of the
business to somebody else who's hungry
who might not be burnt out that's called
being strategic not giving up appreciate
it man
[Applause]
hi Gary how are you
I carry a mix now so I took everything I
learned from you and I found it just
story so gesture is a social media
platform on just area our users can
share anything they want but the only
view contents that they care about and
then we connect them with other
like-minded users who share similar
interests with them so currently none of
the other social media app in the world
is able to do that so will you please
download and check out our app I'm sure
you're gonna love it and we'd love to
have you as an investor for our startup
if it takes off potentially billions of
people around the world will know your
name and you will secure your legacy
forever
can I please know what's the best way
for me to keep in touch with you you can
email me and I'll take a look at the app
great thanks yo hello Gary
how are you hello everyone I'm great my
name is Surat Ibrahim from Nigeria and I
know it's quite weird I'm quite nervous
but I don't know why I'm gathering the
courage to talk from I've been watching
you for all you got knows when five
years six years I'm not sure thank you
my siblings and all so I'm a
photographer
by the way shoutout to Dirac I look up
to him again and so I come from Africa
and in Nigeria everyone is just getting
introduced to things like the technology
don't get me wrong we we have it we have
it but like the young world is just
getting into business and everyone is
just so excited the new blood is getting
in the field yes so I try my best to
create content my own way to sell it to
people of course yeah I know I have my
own issues as you said if you do it for
yourself then you're not doing the right
thing yeah sometimes I do it I do the
content for myself I post it for myself
because I like it not that I don't
consider the client first or the
audience first
so ownership and there's nothing wrong
with that especially because the next
day you can post something for them but
it's important when you
you're doing something for yourself that
that means it may not be bringing value
to somebody else thus you can't expect
something from them there's nothing
wrong with doing everything selfish for
yourself just recognize that that's not
gonna make anybody love that yeah so the
thing is I have some few students
photography students that I teach okay I
held some workshops back home in Nigeria
yes by popular demand
so sometimes did you see the audience
would be so pumped to sign up to some
workshops and things but when you put
them out no one would show up oh maybe
sometimes your pricing or maybe my
pricing would be a bit expensive to them
okay well to me I'm kind of under
prizing my products but they're right
you're wrong you have to understand why
if they're not buying they're not
interested
that means you're overpriced it doesn't
matter what you think so how do you
think I can send a message I really need
to send a message
lower the price audience lower it okay
okay first of all first of all I'm not
I'm not being insistent here but I by I
I use really high and they don't care my
friend the market is always right nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your problems okay
lower your price that's a that's an
important message by the way it's a very
it's a very important message the amount
about when you're trying to sell
something to somebody yeah and they're
not buying it's not their fault but
that's what you're trying to say yeah
which makes you a bad salesman thank you
sir it means you're audacious and you
lack the humility to build a scalable
business you got it thank you sir you're
welcome I love you
[Applause]
hello Gary hello my name is Nene Chang
it's nice to meet you I am the
co-founder of Khamenei the organization
called mompreneur Asia okay therefore I
think that my question would benefit not
only myself but other mothers and
parents out there amazing so I have a
son who is super talented he had his own
TV show on our malaysia satellite TV at
the age of 8 years old he can sing he
can talk and he loves the digital world
okay he wants to get into YouTube okay
so I think that mothers were in the
digital economy needs to walk the talk
right okay I need to know how that I can
support my son or my daughter so that he
could get into the digital world social
media do YouTube video to social media
posting his 11 I have 11 year old and a
six year old by the way okay loves they
love love social media but how can me as
a parent support them doing that
effectively and be safe about it by
watching what they're doing
I mean techniques techniques aw
Simon strategy keeping them safe is
watching them I think what you're asking
me is not how to keep them safe how to
help him grow correct how to keep them I
mean how to have them move forward by
giving them the framework and the
freedom to put out the content without
putting the pressure of it being
successful the number one mistake that
everybody's making in social media is
they want followers you want to help
them tell your son and then your
six-year-old daughter I guess to not
worry about how many subscribers they
have what about content what kind of
content whatever the [ __ ] they want to
make it's true it's true I mean it don't
overthink it
if you overthink the success your kids
are gonna have no shot I mean it thank
you you're welcome my name is my name is
Sat
okay so first time I ever saw you online
I was pissed off I was just so [ __ ]
pissed off yes who the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] yes you tell me I'm doing my
[ __ ] wrong
that's right now it's so tricky I just
kept watching your [ __ ] and like I know
you said a lot of things over the years
but I think the biggest thing that hit
me was the fact that you said everyone
has to be kind yes it is all about your
intention yeah I just want to say thank
you for that
thank you I feel like our society these
days everyone's lost the meaning of the
word kindness yes and you were the one
who started spreading that thank you
outside thank you thank you for saying
that
and brother you know what's really
powerful about your story I'm willing to
be unliked up front to help the reason I
triggered you is because I put pressure
on your [ __ ] I mean it I know you
know and that's why you were thoughtful
you had the strength inside to know it
subconsciously which is why you stayed
the reason the people that you know that
don't like me don't like me is because
I'm not willing to let you [ __ ]
because if I let you [ __ ] you'll
become entitled and you'll lose kids
love kids love when I'm like tell your
parents to go [ __ ] themselves right they
love that but kids kids don't like when
I say hey if your parents want you to go
to college and you want to start a
business you need to leave and you can't
require your parents to help you kids
love when I say screw the parents but
they hate it when I say but if you're
gonna go do your own thing you've got to
do it you've got to get a shitty job and
a shitty apartment and you got to eat
[ __ ] kids want to do what they want but
they want their parents to fund their
dream that's when kids don't like me as
much so that's the game I Gary how are
you good this no questions I mean you
post so much valuable content guess all
the interviews I just wanted to see if
the bottom I had thank you thank you
brother man you you're amazing thank you
so much I'm glad someone like you access
the work that means a lot to me thank
you so much thank you for coming that
was very kind
[Applause]
hi Gary how are you good thanks my name
is Asha Asha and I actually originally
from New Zealand but I noticed in
Malaysia for 22 years and Malaysia is a
fantastic place I agree that's why
hopefully I'll be here too the day I die
so that's that first I'd like to thank
you for giving us all a damn good
talking to thank because I think what
you say really hits people because it's
the absolute truth thank you and the
lies that we all live is absolutely true
thank you so I'm gonna add on this I'll
tell you why I'm more interested in
being historically correct so I have a
proper legacy than to make money in the
short term yeah it's it's better anyway
I have a language Santa here I own an
operator language centre it's very
successful good we are moving to digital
in terms of online learning yes
currently we have an app which is doing
very well
good we're about to launch an actual
fully comprehensive online year so I
understand them yep and the the question
I have is that that online system that
we have now that we're about to launch
is really good but it does require
desktop learning that's the problem yeah
they need to use a keyboard so my
question is we want to go mobile
you have to yeah because you're creating
too much friction yeah I don't remember
the last time I saw a real computer yeah
so what do you see is the future not a
desktop computer so I love that you're
on it right like you have to what you
know I know it's painful when your
infrastructure is built on something
else its money its time but nobody's
going back so you have to make it mobile
first
so how do you see the mobile technology
developing to to be able to encompass
learning that involves a keyboard not a
keyboard but but notice where you're
about to go it is a keyboard yeah but
what what do you see the future of the
keyboard as then the similar to the
future of the pager in a museum thank
you hi Gary
how are you hi I'm Ashley camellia so
first of all if it's not because of two
years back November 1 of your keynotes
I am literally not on any social content
at all so right after that it's only the
right moment of time so within two years
right now I'm running a social media
agency that a team is in the US and I'm
serving us client amazing so I want to
thank you for that of course and as two
years goes true I'd like for me and my
team you like we're discovering the more
niche in the market where we specialize
in gift marketing okay
so I get realized that in turn last year
Christmas you do a recap they're gonna
grow more on give marketing as well as
hiring in your team for you know gifts
animator and I was so yes for even this
year you start to in your newsletter you
start putting in stock timestamp for all
our gifts to incorporate into a smaller
content yes so like for this route like
I'm totally with the same power review
since last year you start implementing
to all of like my client our clients
like totally does we do it like for
personal branding understood and why
it's like your future of vision being
fourths like this type of niche it's
very specific and matza was leveraging
into instead of creating shorties this
is much more consumable like on replay
smaller content on all the community so
are you asking me how viable is
being very one-dimensional around gift
marketing um incorporating gifts into
all other social platform into and
leveraging building up the committee for
personal branding versus like in the
traditional way gifts have also gifts
for personal branding is a very good
tactic and a very tried-and-true thing
that will last for a while gift
communication is now in our culture and
has a very long tail to it yes I just
would tell you that it's always a
vulnerability to be too one-dimensional
yeah so I believe in it you just don't
want somebody like vaynermedia to also
do that but everything else and they
don't want to work with you because
you're just one-dimensional so keep it
but if you're the best at that dimension
then you will always have a seat at the
table so it's a strategic decision that
you have to make and you're visioning
like if this in the future is this gonna
be the next like like the eat thing for
a nother platform of leverage like be
for Givi and sonar like they're growing
from there I don't think so I think it's
just part of the conversation okay you
know gifts and and emojis and slang it's
just a form of communication I don't
think it's a platform in itself it's how
we communicate in platforms we did
incorporate into like community group
management and we see a huge increase of
growth yes and you know the engagement
growth using the the thought leaders got
brand itself so we can see that we come
in hand together with don't ever get too
romantic about one cacked ik because
then you become vulnerable so use this
as the foundation to build on top of
okay or become the best in the world in
just it those are your only two options
so I'm gonna I'm gonna move because I'm
running out of time and I'm not gonna
get to everybody hi Gary
hi I just want to say I'm a huge fan
thank you and you changed my life like
in high school
I'm in my final year in high school and
I've had like a hard time finding
friends or you know but you've got he
wanted me through all of the hard days
and you've inspired me thank you so my
question is I'm I'm an athlete and I'm
into sports science and you always say
like turn your passion into a business
can magnetize anything right yes so I
was thinking okay I'll go to college
I'll go to university get a sport
science degree then open a gym or
Institute okay but then I realized like
maybe I don't have to go to college
maybe maybe I can just start a business
and find a sports scientist to partner
up with me you could yeah but I also
don't I all so think I should go to
college because it's a good experience I
mean I just feel really lost can I have
can I put you in a very good mood yes
whichever one you choose you'll never
know how the other one would have played
out no really and I'm gonna use this for
everybody everybody's so crippled by
decisions but you never know how the
other thing worked out let me give you
an example let's say you don't go to
college and you start this business and
you were a hundred percent right and
it's huge
and you're doing so great but because
you did that you had a fly to America
for a big meeting and your plane crashed
and you died that would be a bad idea or
you think you're gonna go to college cuz
it's a good experience and you'll meet
people you could meet people in a
business you're not gonna know as some
of you guys know I famously passed on
uber twice which means currently I
missed out on 600 million dollars you
could think that's a mistake or if I
would have invested an uber maybe I'd be
somewhere else right now and picking up
a disease that would kill me a year
later baby
I think people overthink decisions
you'll never know what the alternative
would have been so just pick one and do
it so you're saying that if I don't go
to college I won't
on anything like are you I know I
understand what you're asking and
everybody here thought it because it's
nice to have a safety right yeah I just
don't think your degree is as safe as
you think I mean that and and by the way
by the way like it's an important
conversation parents grew up in an era
where a degree was safe but companies
guys watch the world the biggest
companies in the world every day are
stopping requiring college degrees it's
just not as valuable so but it might be
but but for you forget about a general
concept for you
maybe that degree would have been good
what I'm saying is you're not gonna know
so choose live and then if it works out
great and if it doesn't adjust everybody
thinks they can have the perfect
decision there is no perfect decision
there's just life so pick and be happy
with it thank you so much Gary I love
you I love you back hi Gary how are you
I'm good are you tremendous okay just a
quick story might you apply it for
vaynermedia for I followed your content
for five years or the end thank you
yeah it's been amazing so far yeah so I
applied for vaynermedia like four years
so one year into watching your content
okay
try it for two years didn't can you
reply have you tried for internship I
haven't tried for I get it look for free
you know but I didn't get your price was
all good but my question is is actually
how would you actually identify what are
you actually doing right now is the
right thing for you as a human as a
human as in the curia completely the
same answer I just gave that young woman
you have no idea how when would you know
when you die
cool thanks you're welcome guys and I
know it's like fun and everything but
it's the truth
you you don't know like like there is no
there's no time machine there's no
future machine we're all over analyzing
everything like how do you know you
don't like this is why I keep trying to
push people the only thing that I know
seems practical is are you happy are you
happy today feels like it's the right
thing are you like this is important
it's you you can't analyze like I didn't
know that starting a YouTube show for my
wine business was gonna be the reason
that I was gonna have a huge investing
career I couldn't see that there's a
million things I've done wrong it's cuz
I didn't do something that would have
set me somewhere else but I have no idea
you don't know you don't hi Gary
hi first of all I just want to say that
even though I didn't follow you like
anybody other else there yeah I just
[ __ ] love you thank you I don't one
and only that I've ever paid for
something now or like a conference like
thank you so much oh and second of all
I'm actually I would say that I run two
business one is our SEC and one is LUMO
PLT okay I would like to see advice from
you that uh what what would be your
advice for someone like me that I I kind
of like a check of our trade me too and
I like a lot of stuff that don't let
don't let other people tell you to focus
really of course cuz that's your focus
but don't you feel like you never really
achieve nothing people that just means
that you're creative and entrepreneurial
I need to do a hundred things and I
don't mind if twenty of them fail
because for me to just focus on one
thing doesn't work for me so when people
say to you hey you should focus on one
thing that's people who don't [ __ ]
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
what they're saying what they're saying
is for me for me I would do well with
focusing on one thing this is why I give
general advice and then when I do QA I
give specific advice right know you're
like a lot of people me included which
is you'll uh enjoy doing multiple things
it keeps you fresh and creative your
lack of focus is your focus just like it
is for me I also want to say you're just
as handsome as from the you - thank you
[Applause]
hi Gary
how are you gonna follow that up bro Wow
so like I follow a lot of Fitness
youtubers yes and they are like you
having someone fuming zen-like and I
want to do a kind of fitness channel and
travelling style channel but I'm always
by myself
so should I hire someone or should I
just look for someone who wants to I
want to I can you can you put your mic
closer I want to make sure I understood
you follow a bunch of YouTube
influencers your fitness yeah and they
do what they have like a d-roc idea and
you're asking and I want to do a kind of
fitness traveling yeah shall now yep so
I'm asking it if I should hire someone
someone or do it like hey see I'll do
like a Casey yeah well what do you want
to do so man
there's no there's listen the this is
the theme of the whole cup of all the QA
there's no right way there's right for
you so can you afford to pay someone
yeah good
do you like the idea of having company
kind of you know but by the way that's
why I appreciate you the answer is
actually no right like and that's fine
that's um that's amazing yeah it's like
I have someone they're not going to do
like what I'm thinking so so then the
answer to your question is you should
not hire someone yeah okay thank you
you're welcome
guys my time is up thank you so much
Gail thank you